das Fatale an kriegen sind nicht nur
Mord und Totschlag sie zu beenden ist
und gleich schwerer als sie zu beginnen
Frieden schaffen in der Ukraine wird
dadurch erschwert dass der Aggressor
Russland die Vernichtung zum Kriegsziel
erkoren hat und Frieden oder auch nur
Waffenstillstand damit in weite Ferne
gerückt sind
Putins Krieg gegen die Ukraine mehr
Waffen oder mehr Diplomatie jetzt in der
Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
hier im Studio Professor Sönke Neitzel
ist bei uns
Militärhistoriker an der Universität in
potsdamik Ukrainerin und
wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterinnen am
Institut für europäische Politik
außerdem haben sie ein Podcast mit dem
Titel Ukraine Memo
Ute Fink Krämer ist ehemalige
SPD-Bundestagsabgeordnete und jetzt sind
sie Vorsitzende der Plattform zivile
Konfliktbearbeitung Professor Alexander
Liebmann ist bei uns
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler mit
Schwerpunkt Osteuropa und Russland am
osteuropa-institut der Freien
Universität Berlin
dreht sich der Krieg gerade zu Ungunsten
von Putin
tja also was wenn wir das genau wissen
werden wir glaube ich schlauer nicht und
man muss am Anfang sagen dass wir
eigentlich vor allen Dingen nichts
wissen und dass die die Grundlage der
Information um die militärische Lage zu
beurteilen zumindest für uns die jetzt
nicht in den Nachrichtendiensten sind
sehr begrenzt und wir bekommen
Nachrichten von verschiedener Seite dass
die Ukraine
die Initiative gewinnen dass sie an
verschiedenen Fronten gegen offensiven
machen dass sie die innere Linie
ausnutzen
was das genau heißt ob es große
Durchbrüche gibt was das bedeutet
Verlustzahlen jetzt about gessing
denn die meisten Informationen die wir
bekommen sagen wir ehrlich kriegen wir
von der Ukraine kriegen wir von Leuten
die in der Ukraine sind
und das ist für uns unglaublich schwer
es ist zumindest so dass zurzeit die
Ukraine eine Initiative hat das sieht
dann agiert mehr agiert als das Putin
hat was das heißt ob das auch dann ein
Weg ebnet vielleicht für einen Frie
diplomatie ist die große Frage viele
also Vermutung crossing Krämer die
Ukraine die wehrt sich ja ebenso
entschlossen wie geschickt also doch
Frieden schaffen mit Waffen eines Tages
ich glaube nein ich glaube dass die
Diplomatie entscheidend ist dafür dass
Frieden erreicht werden kann
diplomatie ist ja ein Instrument wo wir
in der Öffentlichkeit nur ganz ganz
wenig davon sehen aber all das was
diplomatinnen und Diplomaten machen um
Spielräume auszuloten um Informationen
zu sammeln um Lügen und Wahrheit zu
unterscheiden um eine Stimmung in einem
Land zu erfassen das werden wir brauchen
um eines Tages Frieden in der Ukraine zu
bekommen Stimmung in einem Land erfassen
Frau Melnik wie wird denn in der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung der
Kriegsverlauf das Kriegsgeschehen
wahrgenommen
bereits mehr als sechs Monate vergangen
und wir wissen ganz genau dass die
Ukraine von Anfang an eine große
Bereitschaft gezahlt hat zu kämpfen die
letzten Umfragen zeigen auch dass die
unkraine weiterhin daran glauben dass
die Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnt
an Diplomatie glaubt man nicht das ist
ade das wurde ich glaube bin gerade mit
dem minsker-abkommen aber auch jetzt
mit den Absichten der Russischen
Föderation und weiterhin hofft man sehr
stark dass der Westen die Ukraine diesem
Kampf unterstützen würde gut das Ziel
ist klar ich frage ist wie man es
erreicht das ist ja auch Thema der
Sendung Herr Liebmann wann wäre denn der
Zeitpunkt für Diplomatie gekommen das
genau die Entscheidung der Frage wir
wissen es nicht weil wir uns nicht genau
verstehen wie die Ziele der Parteien
sind insbesondere von Putin Putin hält
uns ganz bewusst im Waage was genau für
ihn Kriegsziel ist man kann aber sagen
dass die Chance für Diplomatie sich
ziemlich erwartet eröffnen können
aufgrund und Logiken die uns vielleicht
gar nicht bekannt sind innenpolitischen
Logiken die wir in Russland sehen und
dann wäre es ganz entscheidend der
Aufgabe der Europäischen Union aller
Parteien diese Chance nicht zu verwerfen
sondern maximal aufzunutzen auf den
Frieden zuzuarbeiten als ich versuche es
noch mal anders zu fragen was ich gesagt
haben ob sich das kriegsgeschick jetzt
gerade wendet letztlich schwer sagen
lässt sich die Frage vielleicht anders
formulieren oder besser beantworten wenn
man fragt wie geschwächt ist Putin
auch das ist natürlich schwer aber wobei
wir immerhin über die russische Armee
mehr wissen als über die ukrainische das
müssen wir es ist ein bisschen anders
Zustand weil wir an der Seite der
Ukraine stehen aber der ukrainische
Generalstab nachvollziehbarer Weise da
sehr zurückhaltend ist also wir sehen
eine Streitmacht die sehr groß ist aber
die ein Stück weit ihre PS nicht auf den
Boden bekommt und im Krieg kommt es eben
auch darauf an die Waffen die man hat
Panzer und ich weiß nicht was auch
effizient einzusetzen und da hat bei
aller Vorsicht im Urteil da hat die
haben die russischen Streitkräfte
massives Problem und da sehen wir die
ukrainische Streitkräfte haben auch
Probleme aber wir müssen sehen dass
eigentlich schon seit 2008
seit dem Gipfel im Bukarest die Ukraine
die griechischen Streitkräfte in
Ausbildung von naturstreitkräften sind
und insbesondere seit 2014 und auch die
Bundeswehr beteiligt sich ja daran was
nicht im breiten Sinne bekannt ist aber
vor allem die Briten und Amerikaner und
das trägt natürlich jetzt auch kann man
also die Ukraine sind offenbar wendiger
sind schneller sie machen eine
schnellere Gegenstöße sie können mit dem
wenigen Gerät was sie haben besser und
effizienter umgehen und wir sehen ja
dass die russischen Streitkräfte nicht
weiter vormarschiert ist denn ein Sieg
der Ukraine meine ich den Aggressor aus
dem Land zu schmeißen er ist der
realistisch da kann ich nur auf die
Umfragen verweisen die ich auch kenne
und da würde ich sagen dass ich diese
Meinung der Ukraine nicht mit über 90
Prozent glauben man könnte die Grenze
mindestens vom 24 Februar wenn ich
darüber hinaus Stichwort Grimm erreichen
das halte ich für unrealistisch also
wenn die Ukraine erschaffen würde die
Landbrücke zurückzugewinnen also auch
Regionen die ja wirklich wichtig sind
die ökonomisch wichtig sind
landwirtschaftlich weit entwickelt das
wäre ein gigantischer Erfolg schon an
erster Schritt Song zurückzuholen und
dann die Landbrücke aber mir fehlt die
die Vorstellung dass man die Creme oder
den dombos zurück aber weil wir dürfen
auch die Russen nicht unter
jetzt glauben die Ukraine an den Sieg
das tun die Russen auch sie glauben
sogar an einen Wiederaufstieg und das
sind ein Großteil der Russen glaubt dass
als imperiale Großmacht ist hat ja zu
Beginn dieses Krieges dieses
aggressionskrieges gegen Russland
versuchen gegeben auch von ukrainischer
Seite Vermittlung Türkei zum Beispiel
mit den Russen mit der russischen
Führung mit Putin Verhandlungen
aufzunehmen das ist Brust abgewiesen
worden wie geht man denn jetzt aus ihrer
Position dass sie sagen Waffen
Krieg bringt nichts Verhandlungen
Diplomatie auf dem Weg zum Frieden wie
geht man mit einem Land um und einem
politischen Führer wie Putin der darauf
pfeift auf friedliche Weise den Konflikt
zu beenden sondern einfach den Krieg
weiterführt
also vielleicht muss man erstmal
unterscheiden was sie eben gesagt haben
dass ich auch so dass wir nicht sicher
sind was wirklich die Kriegsziele von
Potenz sind wir haben seine Ansagen aus
dem Februar wo er für überraschend
wahrscheinlich auch für viele
Politikwissenschaftler überraschend eben
dieses imperiale Motiv also ein
großrussisches Reich wieder herzustellen
eben sich zu eigen gemacht hat was ja
vorher nur von
Rechtsradikalen politischen Minderheiten
in seinem Land vertreten wurde wir
hatten andererseits im Dezember seine
klare Ansage an die NATO wo es um
russische Sicherheitsinteressen ging wo
man zwar daraus ablesen konnte das
Russland darum kämpft wieder den Status
einer Großmacht zu erhalten einer
politischen Großmacht nicht unbedingt an
einem militärischen sondern einer
politischen aber wo eben Forderungen da
waren wo es um klassische
Sicherheitsinteressen ging und da jetzt
erstmal festzustellen was ist denn
eigentlich das was
die wirkliche Begründung ist oder
andersrum formuliert Ziele können sich
auch wieder ändern wenn Putin feststellt
weil es wir haben ja letztlich einen
abnutzungs Weg wo keine Seite wirklich
eben so aussieht als ob sie gewinnen
könnte wenn Putin feststellt dass er das
eine Ziel was er im Februar aus der
Tasche gezogen hat nicht erreichen kann
geht er dann vielleicht zu den anderen
Zielen zurück und dann hätten wir
plötzlich Diplomatie auf einer ganz
anderen Ebene dann ginge es nämlich um
den strategischen Dialog zwischen
Russland und den USA dann ging er es um
das was beiden angekündigt hat am ersten
August in Bezug auf die
Überprüfungskonferenz des nicht
verbreitungsvertrags dass er ein
Interesse daran hat mit Russland über
ein nachfolgerabkommen zu
dem new start-abkommen zu verhandeln da
sind wir dann auf einer Ebene wo die
Enttäuschung die berechtigte
Enttäuschung der Ukraine darüber dass
die Diplomatie die sie wahrgenommen
haben in Bezug auf den ja schon 2014
begonnenen Krieg in der Ukraine eben aus
ihrer Sicht nichts ausgetragen hat wo
wir
die im Grunde umgehen können mache ich
denn das Interesse an einem
Nachfolgeabkommen von new start haben
wir eigentlich alle das ist also dass
das Abrüstungsabkommen für die atomare
Bewaffnung sieht man noch mal weil das
jetzt gerade angesprochen worden ist im
Westen glaubt ihr sicherlich die
Mehrheit es ging eine Putin eigentlich
um was ganz anderes nämlich nicht um die
Ukraine sondern um Westeuropa er
fürchtet auch nicht westliche Waffen
sondern er fürchte das westliche
Gesellschaftssystem und diese Einflüsse
die ihnen in seiner und seine Entourage
in ihrer Macht extrem Gefährten würden
ist das ein richtiges narrativ kommen
wir da der Wahrheit über die
warenabsichten von Putin schon ziemlich
nahe ich werde das ja vorsichtig das
Problem ist wir haben mehrere narrative
und mehrere narrative spiegeln
wahrscheinlich nur Teil der Wahrheit ab
nämlich in der russischen Elite und
sicherlich unter den Leuten mit den
Putin spricht und die ihn beeinflussen
der Bevölkerung steht hinter Putin ich
werde auch sehr vorsichtig wir haben
sehr schlechte Datenlage dazu wir haben
die Meinungsumfragen und ich gebe Ihnen
jetzt ein Beispiel dafür warum man sehr
vorsichtig sein wenn man die Leute
direkt fragt ob sie den Krieg
unterstützen sagen tatsächlich die
Mehrheit ja wenn man aber die Leute
fragt sollte man den Krieg sofort
stoppen haben wir trotzdem extrem viele
idealsagen und extrem viele sagen auch
ja wenn man sagt würden sie unterstützen
weil Putin morgen Befehl geben würde den
Krieg zu intensivieren und Kiew
ja das ist das Problem die Mehrheit sei
gleichzeitig wir sind bereit den Krieg
zu stoppen und wir sind bereit den Krieg
bis zum Ende zu führen was heißt das für
mich für mich bedeutet es eigentlich die
meisten Russen und Russen sind wir dem
aktuellen Zustand extrem unzufrieden und
falls Putin morgen den anbieten würde
etwas was als ein Sieg aussehen würde
aber Ende von dem Horror in dem sich
viele befinden würden viele sagen ja gut
das wird aber die Ukraine aller
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht akzeptieren
ist denn die Angst nach wie vor in ihrem
Land sehr groß dass der Westen
möglicherweise auch Druck ausübt und
sagt kommt versucht mit den Russen mit
Russland euch zu einigen es gibt ja auch
immer wieder Hinweis dann muss man eben
auch auf
jemals ukrainische Gebiete verzichten
ist das immer eine Angst dass
möglicherweise der Westen gerade
Deutschland auch einknickt in diesem
Kampf der Unterstützung des Kampfes der
Ukraine gegen Russland ich würde nicht
sagen das ist die Angst einfach man
hofft dass die Ukraine nicht alleine
gelassen wird ich bin aber nicht damit
ich glaube einverstanden dass die Ziele
von Putin unbekannt sind die waren schon
bekannt seit 2014 eigentlich die große
Welle von Propaganda begann 2014 und
seit 2014 seit der Annexion der Grieben
haben die Ukraine gesagt das Ziel von
Putin ist das Ganze Ukraine zu die ganze
Ukraine zu erobern das hat man auch am
notstream 2 die ganze Zeit hingewiesen
und mich persönlich hat es auch
überrascht ich bin eher auch im Bereich
des kursanalyse unterwegs und manchmal
frage ich mich warum hat man die
Propaganda gar nicht analysiert die
russische Propaganda gibt uns ein sehr
guten Einblick was eigentlich der Creme
will und gibt viele für die Ukraine sind
klipp und klar der putin will es geht
zuerst den Süden der Ukraine den Osten
der Ukraine zu gewinnen geopolitisch die
Ukraine zu schwächen geoökonomisch die
Ukraine zu schwächen wenn Putin gelingen
würde dann würden der Ukraine zu
bekommen den Osten der Ukraine zu
bekommen bis mir pro bis zum Schluss das
würde bedeuten dass die Ukraine die
Schwarzerde verlieren würde denn Zugang
zum Schwarzen Meer verlieren würde und
da sind die Anbaugebiete für Getreide
vor allen Dingen und da sind und ihm da
fragt sich auch die Ukraine was sie
bleiben dann von der Ukraine als Staat
und heute und gestern zum Beispiel wurde
schon ein strategischer Artikel vom
oberen befallsinhaber der Ukraine
veröffentlicht wo genau die Ziele der
Ukraine definiert werden und übrigens
die Creme steht auch da ganz genau
genannt und man schließt nicht aus dass
die Creme in in Zukunft der okkupiert
wird zum Beispiel mit der die
ukrainische Gesellschaft kann sich gar
nicht vorstellen dass die Creme für
immer das russische Territorium
ist das so die cremeterische Bevölkerung
sehr stark und eigentlich die
was würde denn passieren jetzt aus ihrer
Sicht auch was militärische und
politische Strategien für die Zukunft
angeht wenn Putin zumindest einen Teil
seiner Kriegsziele erreichen würde
also da würde ich meiner Vorrednerin
zustimmen ich meine wir müssen ja
versuchen als Westen die Ukraine als
lebensfähigen Staat zu erhalten und mit
der jetzigen Frontlinie geht das nicht
meines Erachtens und ich glaube er würde
auch das Ziel so definieren das ist
immer schwierig weil wir sind aus der
Geschichte
aufgrund von öffentlichen Reden
Kriegsziele zu interpretieren geht
meistens schief aber wir haben ja nun
leider keine anderen Quellen aber ich
glaube schon dass es um die Zerstörung
des Staates Ukraine geht und dass wir
auch wenn es da mal andere Signale gibt
darauf relativ wenig geben sollten und
die Frage ist wie kommen wir da raus und
es ist ja auch genannt worden Diplomatie
also ich glaube Deutschland wird da
überhaupt gar keine Rolle spielen und
auch die EU wird letztlich keine Rolle
spielen was ich mir vorstellen kann das
ist das irgendwann
nicht in diesem Jahr aber irgendwann
beiden und Putin sich in Genf treffen
und es ist letztlich eine Entscheidung
der Amerikaner warum weil Deutschland
und auch die EU ist sicherheitspolitisch
ein Zwerg
sie waren ein Zwerg sie sind ein Zwerg
und Sie werden ein Zwerg bleiben und
damit haben sie auch wenn Sie ein Zwerg
sind haben sie beim Spiel riesen immer
noch nicht mitzuspielen und wenn die
Deutschen wir heute angekündigt jetzt
also bei der minenabwehr der Ukraine
helfen ist das sicherlich aller
ehrenwert aber natürlich eigentlich im
dritten Witz und die Ukraine setzt auf
die Amerikaner ein Stück weit auf die
Briten auf die Polen und die werden dann
auch weil sie militärisch relevant waren
politisch das Spiel bestimmt natürlich
können die Amerikaner sagen einigt euch
wenn ihr Amerikaner sagen wir
unterstützen euch nicht mehr wird die
Ukraine russisch das ist ganz hell wird
der Europa also jetzt ich meine jetzt
Westeuropa EU Europa NATO Europa
letztendlich in diesem ganzen Spiel auch
ein Spielball sein
gewisser Hinsicht ist es tatsächlich der
Fall weil eben wir jetzt über die
militärische Konfrontation sprechen wo
auch Großteil der militärischen Hilfe an
die Ukraine von den Vereinigten Staaten
kommen das ist allerdings nicht
unbedingt der Zustand mit dem wir uns
zufriedenstellen müssen weil die Kosten
des Konflikts für Europa und für
Deutschland sind enorm und es geht hier
nicht nur um die Energiedebatte alleine
sie würde ausreichen um diese Kosten zu
betonen wir sehen vor unseren Augen wie
zahlreiche wirtschaftliche
Verflechtungen in Eurasien brechen und
das wird europäische Wirtschaften sehr
lange belasten also sie haben sehr
wahrscheinlich recht es kommt nicht auf
uns an aber es ist auch ein Zustand
leider das ist ein extrem
problematischer Zustand was aus meiner
Sicht eben das Thema Diplomatie
besonders wichtig macht weil Deutschland
könnte bei dem besten Intentionen nicht
eine entscheidende militärische Rolle
spielen einfach aus dem Zustand auch
keine entscheidende diplomatische
also jetzt befürchte ich es tatsächlich
der Fall dass die deutsche Rolle in der
Diplomatie leider gering sein wird aber
ich bin nicht sicher dass es der einzige
Weg war den man seit Anfang des kriegens
gehen konnte und ich bin nicht sicher
dass der Dauerzustand ist also da könnte
Deutschland theoretisch andere Rolle
einnehmen
gut ich kann da direkt drauf reagieren
das Spannende ist ja dass Diplomatie
nicht immer nur das direkte verhandeln
ist sondern eben auch das Ausschöpfen
aller Umwege und aller indirekten Wege
und Deutschland hat eine Menge
hocherfahrene diplomatinnen und
Diplomaten die im Hintergrund wirken
können die den UN-Generalsekretär
unterstützen können die
unterstützen können mit Berichten aus
Russland zum Beispiel
die eben vertraulich dann übermittelt
werden es ist ja nicht nur sind ja nicht
nur die Nachrichtendienste die eben
Informationen sammeln in Rheinland
sondern es sind ganz entscheidend auch
diplomatinnen und Diplomaten die
übrigens auch mehr Chancen haben mit der
Zivilgesellschaft in Kontakt zu kommen
als das vielleicht die Militärs oder die
Geheimdienste können und wenn jetzt wenn
man jetzt sagt es kann aber ein eine
Bereitschaft für Verhandlungen dadurch
entstehen dass Verhandlungen die Putin
zumindest auch für wichtig befunden hat
nämlich Verhandlungen über
strategisches Gleichgewicht über
Sicherheit und so weiter auch da kann
Deutschland was beitragen nach
Deutschland hat die entsprechende
diplomatische Expertise Deutschland
stellt die
Generalsekretärin der OSZE also der
Organisation für Sicherheit und
Zusammenarbeit in Europa im Augenblick
Deutschland hatte diese vielfältigen
wissenschaftlichen
zivilgesellschaftlichen Kontakte viel
viel mehr als die USA noch das ist jetzt
nicht so dass es massenhaft
Städtepartnerschaften von us-stätten mit
Städten in Russland gibt wo eben drauf
aufgebaut werden könnte
wie kann man aber im Sinne also ich habe
heute gerade ein Newsletter gelesen eben
vom
deutsch-russischen Jugendwerk wo eben
die Frage ist wie hält man jetzt im
Augenblick die Kontakte damit man sie
wenn man sie wieder braucht sie dann
eben wieder nutzen kann die nutzt man
gerade nicht um jetzt heute mit den
Leuten darüber zu diskutieren wie denkt
ihr von Putin das was jetzt gerade
skizziert haben ist ja der Wunsch nach
einer Friedenslösung die für alle
erträglich ist die kein Blut mehr
fließen lässt aber das was sie skizziert
haben jetzt gesagt halten sie das in
absehbarer Zeit für realistisch also da
erhalte ich es mit meinem Nachbarn das
ist unvermutete Situationen geben kann
wo sowas ganz schnell realistisch wird
und dann muss man vorbereitet sein dann
kann man nicht anfangen erst mal
zusammen zu sammeln noch und zu sagen
was können wir jetzt eigentlich machen
ein window of opportunity also ein
Fenster der Gelegenheit heißt ja immer
dass ich ganz plötzlich alles öffnet und
darauf kann und darf und soll man sich
vorbereiten um das das in der Ukraine
das verfängt in dem Sinne dass man da
bereit wäre aufeinander zuzugehen was
sind da dich Voraussetzungen dass alle
russischen Truppen abgezogen sind das
alles was der Ukraine gehört
völkerrechtlich gehört
zurückgegeben wird oder würde man da
auch schon vorher einen Schritt
unternehmen ich hätte ja gesagt am
Anfang des kriege es gab erst durchaus
Versuche von ukrainischer Seite als
silence gedacht dass er möglicherweise
in zwei Wochen nicht mehr Präsident ist
da etwas zu unternehmen was wäre da die
Voraussetzung jeder Krieg ändert mit
einer Diplomatie am Ende des Krieges
werden auch diplomatische Verhandlungen
stattfinden die Frage die Frage
vielleicht anders formuliert das wird
aber hier in diesem Fall im Falle und
Kriegen und Russland bestimmte Fall sein
die Frage ist nur welche Seite stärken
wir wenn wir jetzt über Diplomatie
sprechen was bedeutet das für uns sollen
wir jetzt die Waffenlieferungen
einstellen das wäre für mich auch jetzt
ich würde gerne sagen was wie sehen sie
soll diplomatische sollen diplomatische
Versuche parallel laufen oder soll dann
sollen die Waffenlieferungen eingestellt
werden für die Ukraine zum Beispiel die
Ukraine schließt nicht aus dass
Diplomatie im Spiel sein wird für die
Ukraine ist aber lebend wichtig dass die
schwere Waffen an die Ukraine geliefert
werden wir haben das schon gesehen was
was in budja passiert als die Ukraine
noch nicht sozusagen auf diese
Aggressionen vorbereitet war und für die
Ukraine wenn wir jetzt zurück auf diese
auf ihre Frage zurückkommen das ist klar
die der Okkupierung alle Territorien und
darunter auch der Krim und jetzt wir
gestern bereits veröffentlicht wurde ist
auch für die Ukraine wichtig dass die
die Ukraine weiterhin nicht beschlossen
wird durch verschiedene Raketen die aus
dem Territorium von Russland kommen und
daher stellt die Ukraine sich auch die
Frage wie kann die Ukraine das Sichern
und jetzt auch gibt es eine große
Forderung in der Ukraine
Langstreckenraketen in die Ukraine zu
liefern ich glaube da wird da wird
werden wir auch hier im Westen viel mehr
darüber diskutieren welche Waffen
liefern wir die in der Ukraine aber die
Ukraine weiß genau was sie will ich bin
mir aber nicht sicher ob der Westen weiß
was er will sie meinen damit
Gefechtsfeld Raketen glaube ich die und
Granaten die also ein bisschen
weiterfliegen und auch in das Hinterland
der russischen Truppen gelangen da gibt
es ja auch entsprechende Waffensysteme
die da gerade offensichtlich geliefert
werden an dazu habe ich Sie richtig
verstanden bzw bei Ihnen richtig
nachgelesen dass
es eigentlich erst zu Verhandlungen
kommen kann wenn Russland so militärisch
geschwächt ist das Putin tatsächlich
gezwungen ist aus militärischen Gründen
dass einzugehen dass es so lange der
Krieg weitergeht dass bis solange Putin
glaubt er könne tatsächlich Siegen also
ich glaube dieser Punkt hat sehr viel
mit Wahrnehmung zu tun und die Frage das
klassische wäre wenn Putin merkt über
eine längere Zeit er kommt militärisch
nicht weiter er muss es an der
militärisch schwächeren Positionen weil
die russische Probleme hat Korruption
wie auch immer man droht alles zu
verlieren weil die Armee vielleicht
zusammenbricht oder in Teilen
zusammenbricht und dann sagt besser
jetzt ein Waffenstillstand das Problem
ist dann dass dann in so einem Moment
die Ukraine natürlich sagen würde also
jetzt machen wir natürlich kein
Waffenstillstand also wenn man die
historischen Beispiele sich ansieht dann
ist es leider so also wir alle wollen
dass dieser Krieg endet aber es ist
leider so nur mal den Ersten Weltkrieg
da begann schon seit 15
Friedensverhandlungen über Dänemark und
so und jeder hat immer gesagt er hat
jetzt gerade ein ungünstiger Moment und
wenn der eine in der schwächeren
Position war sagte er naja also jetzt
wird natürlich zu schwach und wir müssen
weiter kämpfen also wenn eine solche
Situation eintrete würde wahrscheinlich
sehr selenski nicht sagen jetzt hören
wir auf sondern jetzt oben und noch die
Krim zurück und so und
von daher und das hängt eben sehr stark
auch von innenpolitischen Fragen ab also
die Kalkulation wenn ich weiterkämpfe
komme ich dann in politisch so und dann
Probleme weil ich vielleicht doch
general Immobilien machen muss weil ich
sonst keine Soldaten mehr habe das kann
ich mir nicht leisten also mache ich
lieber Schluss verkaufe das irgendwie
als Sieg in meiner meiner Propaganda
mache mal drei Jahre Pause und dann
werden die Karten neu gemischt auch das
zeigt die Geschichte der frozen Konflikt
der da möglicherweise
wird und das dass das also das Problem
ist glaube ich dass wir uns vielleicht
noch eine Situation eines
Waffenstillstandes eines defacto
Waffenstillstandes vorstellen können
aber nicht eines friedensstoßes und da
haben wir natürlich genug historische
Parallelen also Russland oder was aus
spanische reich aber über 300 Jahre
Krieg geführt weil kein Krieg wirklich
eine Lösung brachte und wir wollen
natürlich eigentlich ein Frieden der
eine Lösung bringen kann bei Ihnen mit
mit dem Rückzug und das wird Putin so
lange nicht akzeptieren wie er das
militärisch noch irgendwie verhindern
können
Blick auf den Waffel stehen stand ich
glaube so schauen wir einfach auf das
Jahr 2014 hat eigentlich versucht den
Waffenstillstand zu halten was hat
Russland gemacht Russland in dem
Zeitraum hat sich aufgerüstet was hat
der Westen gemacht hat der Westen
wirklich die Zeit genutzt um Diplomatie
auszuschöpfen und die Ukraine auch
militärisch zu stärken da er frage ich
mich wann wir den Waffenstillstand wenn
wir jetzt für den Waffenstillstand
plädieren dann welche Garantien können
wir der Ukraine liefern dass das
Russland eigentlich diese Zeit nicht
dafür nutzen würde sich wieder
aufzurüsten es geht man muss sich
möglicherweise von der von der
Vorstellung befreien dass man als erstes
einen Waffenstillstand macht und dann
anschließend über Frieden verhandelt das
hat an anderen Stellen auch nicht
funktioniert und das heißt dann immer
dass einer die eskalationsdominanz hat
nämlich der der den Waffenstillstand
bricht und damit wird es genauso
schwierig wie das was sie geschildert
haben immer der der sich gerade ein
bisschen im Vorteil sieht will nicht
verhandeln sondern will erst noch weiter
kämpfen und wenn es ihm dann schlechter
geht dann sagt er nein ich muss das
zurückerobern das hat mir übrigens in
Afghanistan über viele Jahre noch das
Problem deswegen ist ja gerade die Frage
ob man nicht mit Diplomatie eben jetzt
nach neuen Wegen sucht und guckt gibt es
etwas worüber man verhandeln kann was
eben nichts mit dem augenblicklichen
Krieg zu tun hat was aber unter
Umständen von Putin in seiner verqueren
Logik als Sieg verkauft werden könnte
und wenn er dann hingeht am Schluss und
mit seiner ganzen Medien macht und allem
was er an Macht hat sagt also ich habe
diese spezialoperation nur durchgeführt
weil die Russen die Quatsch die
Amerikaner nicht richtig bereit waren
über Sicherheitsgarantien für Russland
im
nuklearstrategischen Bereich zu
verhandeln und das habe ich jetzt
erreicht und dafür hat sich das gelohnt
dann werden auch nicht viele Leute in
Russland dem widersprechen sondern die
die froh sind dass der Krieg zu Ende ist
werden Krieg ist zu Ende die die ihm
alles abkaufen werden sagen jawohl hat
er recht also das ist durchaus auch eine
Möglichkeit und das hat dann eben
maximalen
andere Frage wir hantieren ja mit den
Begriffen Frieden und und
Waffenstillstand also was ich mir noch
vorstellen kann in absehbarer Zeit ist
ein Waffenstillstand und danach folgend
ein frozen Konflikt den ihr zwischen
Israel und Palästina seit 75 Jahren
haben seit weit über 70 Jahren
inzwischen Indien und Pakistan aber ein
friedliches Nebeneinander oder eine gute
nachbarschaftliches nebeneinander in
einer Friedensordnung zwischen
Westeuropa und Russland das ist doch
eigentlich so weit weg dass man sich gar
nicht darüber
gar nicht nachdenken möchte und will
wann das tatsächlich mal wieder oder es
war ja eigentlich wahrscheinlich noch
nie aber jedenfalls in einem
auskömmlichen in einem gedeihlichen
Zusammenleben endet oder mün müssen wir
uns von einer wirklichen Frieden auf
lange Zeit verabschieden ist das der
Waffenstillstand das optimale da
sprechen wir jetzt mal die Ukraine oder
nein also da ist das tatsächlich ein
Szenario dass wir auf sehr sehr lange
Eiszeit in Osteuropa blicken werden wo
Kontakte extrem eingeschränkt werden das
muss man allerdings in einem globalen
Kontext sehen und der globale Kontext
ist da leider ein sehr problematisches
die
globale die starke Eiszeiten Osteuropa
bedeutet auch den Rückzug der
Globalisierung denn Rückzug der
wirtschaftlichen Kontakte nicht nur in
Russland sondern auch mit China mit
vielen anderen Ländern in Eurasien und
das muss einfach jeder Person klar sein
dass wiederhole ich jedes Mal wenn ich
über dieses Thema spreche in der
welthunde Globalisierung ist jede
deutsche jeder Deutsche jeder Mensch in
der Welt
ärmer
und wir sprechen zum Teil von Leuten in
den globalen Süden die auch deutlich
ärmer sind das heißt ein Zustand in dem
der wirtschaftliche Beziehungen
dauerhaft gekappt sind ist einfach kein
der zufriedenstellend ist wir brauchen
einen Ausweg darauf bedeutet dass das
man eine politische Partnerschaft
Partnerschaft der Werte haben der
definitiv nicht nicht unter Putin aber
der Kalte Krieg hat uns gelehrt dass wir
auch mit zwei Systemen die einander zum
Teil offen sagen wir wollen Sie gerne
beerdigen irgendwie zusammenarbeiten
kann und das wird genau die Aufgabe der
Diplomatie sein wie es im 21 Jahrhundert
funktioniert aber es gibt einfach keinen
Ausweg daraus das Problem ist nur zum
Kalten Krieg einen brechen F letztlich
ein Status Quo verteilt hat man dann
proxyvers in Afrika forte aber einmal im
Status Quo festhielt und jetzt haben wir
ja genau ein Land mit China und Russland
die den Status Quo verändern und wir
haben uns nicht lächerlich zu machen die
sagen können hauptsache das Gas fließt
und Brechen der hat eben und die NATO
das auch diskutiert das war eine klare
Status der war eingefroren und dann
konnte man auch Handel treiben und wenn
wir wieder dahin kämen wenn wir wenn wir
wenn die russischen Streitkräfte sich
aus der Ukraine zurückziehen würden ich
spinne jetzt mal und dann dann könnten
wir wieder dahin kommen dass wir sagen
na gut also da gibt es Werte Probleme
aber wir nehmen auch ein Handel wieder
auf nur das wird wahrscheinlich nicht
passieren und auch in China in dieser
Koexistenz wir hatten Probleme
schreibt ja auf eine Eskalation zu und
ich ob wir sagen können wir als Westen
sagen
Taiwans about Taiwan
das wahrscheinlich nicht und diese diese
Illusion die wir hatten naja da gibt es
Differenzen da gibt es einen Delta aber
eigentlich können wir doch irgendwie
doch zusammen Handel treiben zumindest
dieser Handel wird sogar
ein Krieg verhindern das war doch eine
Illusion wir haben uns doch letztlich
sie haben völlig Recht ohne
Globalisierung sind wir ärmer aber wir
haben unsere reicher gemacht als wir
sind man der Deutsche Bank Chef gestern
seling hat ja heute gesagt dass uns
nicht ein zweites Mal in eine solche
Abhängigkeit begeben bei China wie das
in Russland mit der Energie war was in
Handel angeht wir müssen zwar nicht
schlagartig aber sukzessive diese
Abhängigkeit lösen das würde ja aber
eigentlich letztendlich aus
Sicherheitsgründen der internationalen
Sicherheit auch der westlichen
Sicherheit tatsächlich notgedrungen
zumindest eine Teil in eine Teil die
Globalisierung führen ja und das ist
genau ein Problem ich glaube man muss da
wirklich unterscheiden zwischen
verschiedenen Szenarien dass man eine
zum Beispiel Diversifizierung von
Lieferquellen für Energie braucht oder
dass man auch Aufbau von strategischen
Produktionen z.B Pharma-Bereich in
Europa in Deutschland braucht dagegen
würde auch niemand streiten da wurde
auch extrem viel vernachlässigt in den
letzten Jahren aber das bedeutet nicht
dass man auf alle möglichen
wirtschaftlichen und auch natürlich
zivilgesellschaftlichen und kulturellen
Kontakte verzichtet weil wir müssen
einfach verstehen so als Szenario führt
nicht nur zu der wirtschaftlichen
Verarmung so ein Szenario zementiert
leider ein Status Quo das noch viel
schlimmer sein wird als das was wir
jetzt haben gestatten Sie mir eine
Analogie wollen wir dass wir im Europa
im Osten Europa ein nuklearen Iran
bekommen der Bevölkerung hat die massiv
Anti westlich ist wo jede und jeder weiß
wir leiden weil Europa uns das angetan
hat und in jeder globalen Angelegenheit
und Russland hat genug Möglichkeiten das
zu machen sich gegen den Westen stellt
sie quer den besten stellt und immer
Länder wie China unterstützt bei der ja
komplexer sind in ihrer Außenpolitik
aber ist es nicht schon so
20 Jahren das ist nicht so die russische
Bevölkerung hat sich gerade extrem
europäisiert in den letzten Jahren
Putins Regierung ist eine archaische
eine veraltete fast mittelalterliche
Diktatur die aber über ein Land regiert
hat wo sehr viele Leute modern gedacht
haben und das dürfen wir unter keinen
Umständen nicht möglicherweise aber auf
in der Immigration sind Frau Mendig ich
wollte noch mal auf Deutsch Exporte
zurückkommen deutscher Exporte nur nach
Polen und Tschechien sind höher als nach
China und ich glaube wenn wir jetzt die
Ukraine so be als Land in welches man
auch investieren kann dann bietet sie
auch einen so eigentlich große Chancen
für die für Deutschland aber was ich
glaube ich womit ich mich nicht abfinden
kann dass wir darüber sprechen ob wir
ärmer sind wir haben jetzt zu tun mit
einem System wo filtrationslager in der
Ukraine gebaut werden von Russland und
wir sprechen darüber ob wir
ärmer werden das ist klar das wird uns
alle betreffen aber ich glaube es geht
eher darum in welchem System wir und
unsere Kinder leben würden und so ein
System wo eigentlich die Macht regiert
ja das wünsche ich mir nicht und ich
kann mir vorstellen dass man das
bedeutet nicht dass wir jetzt mit
Russland die Beziehungen auf Eis legen
wir müssen halt auch jetzt uns damit
abfinden dass von Russland eine Gefahr
ausgeht das haben wir immer nicht
berücksichtigt und dementsprechend
unsere Strategien aufbauen das bedeutet
aber nicht dass wir die Beziehungen
jetzt auf Eis legen klar reduzieren und
einfach schauen russ zunächst die
Bedrohung wie sollen wir jetzt in Europa
eigentlich unser Europa und die
Europäische Union aufrecht erhalten das
ist für uns die Aufgabe bei den
Sanktionen noch mal nachlegen um da mehr
Nachdruck noch zu schaffen also nicht
nur Waffen zu liefern sondern auch die
Sanktionen gegenüber Russland noch mal
verschärfen aus ihrer Sicht die
Europäische Union hat diese Mechanismen
Sanktionen das ist nicht die Europäische
Union ist an sich nicht die militärische
Macht und was ihr jetzt sehen mit Blick
darauf wie wir russland versucht jetzt
den Westen zu erpressen durch Gas und so
weiter das Aktionen wirken und
dementsprechend müssen wir prüfen ob ob
es keiner Wege dann entstehen dass
bestimmte Unternehmen die sension
umgehen oder Russland durch die
Sanktionen umgeht das ist wichtig und
dementsprechend haben wir wir müssen
Aussagen bis heute haben wir nicht
darauf geeinigt dass wir jetzt auf Gas
verzichten aus Russland und bestimmt
gibt es andere Wege und andere Schaden
von Sanktionen die man einführen kann
sind in Sanktionen ein probates ziviles
Mittel Russland wenn man sie schon nicht
militärisch besiegen kann zumindest
wirtschaftliche in die Knie zu zwingen
es kommt sehr darauf an was für eine
Form von Sanktionen das sind noch also
die
sanktionsinstrumentarien haben sich ja
auch in den letzten 30 Jahren deutlich
weiterentwickelt ich glaube das
sanktionieren von politischen und
wirtschaftlichen
Eliten die eben ein Interesse daran
haben EU-weit zu agieren und die das
dann nicht mehr können ist ein
sinnvolles sanktionsinstrumentarium wo
man auch einigermaßen eben die die
Nebenkosten die das macht abschätzen
kann und das trifft die richtigen schon
bei den banksanktionen hat das zum
Beispiel dazu geführt dass die Russen
die sich dem Krieg und den damit
verbundenen
autorisierungs eben Tendenzen ziehen
wollten plötzlich ohne Zugriff auf ihr
Geld in den Ländern in diese geflohen
sind saßen das ist ganz sicher nicht das
was wir uns gewünscht haben dass wir die
europäisierten Eliten also jetzt
akademischen Eliten davon abhalten
wollen das Land zu verlassen sondern
sagen sollen die doch in Russland
bleiben und sich da in diesen Krieg
einbeziehen lassen direkt oder indirekt
so und
da genauer hinzugucken ist wichtig und
auch hin zu gucken
ob eben bestimmte Sanktionen sogar
kontraproduktiv sind also die de facto
Sanktionen im Wissenschaftsbereich die
quer über alle Fachrichtungen gingen
auch über die Germanistik oder die
Archäologie oder was weiß ich die
Sprachwissenschaft also wo wirklich
keinerlei militärische Verwendung
denkbar ist die empfinde ich zum
Beispiel aus ausgesprochen
kontraproduktiv es ist eigentlich eher
im Gegenteil so dass man da wo
Konflikte stark werden ähm sagen muss
wir müssen eben ja Beziehungen so
aufrecht erhalten dass die anderen
merken wir sind eben kein Feind je mehr
die Beziehungen abgebrochen werden desto
mehr sagen ja dann auch irgendwann junge
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
in Russland naja
also uns wird immer erzählt die die
EU-Bürger sind unsere Feinde vielleicht
ist da ja was dran
erlebt man Putin sagte in der
Öffentlichkeit immer ihr könnt uns alle
mal im Westen wir brauchen wir sind von
euren Sanktionen überhaupt nicht
betroffen und das macht uns gar nichts
aus betroffen schon aber es macht uns
nichts aus jetzt gibt es ja dieses
gehaltpapier russischer Beamter die was
das Gegenteil sagen dass wieso wohl sehr
wirksam sind und ganz schlimmen Schaden
anrichten in Russland oder anrichten
werden es wird von einem Rückfall von
vielen Jahrzehnten in der
technologischen technologischen Standard
im technologischen Niveau gegenüber dem
Westen gesprochen dass das ein
katastrophale Auswirkungen auch für die
typische Bevölkerung hat bis hin zu
möglicher Lebensmittelknappheit ist da
was dran an diesem Geheimpapier sehr
interessant dass es in Westen gespielt
worden ist denn das ist ja eigentlich ja
top secret damit weiß der Feind der
Russen oder der Gegner der Russen
bezeichnen sie ja unsere als Feinde
genau wo es im Land Schwierigkeiten gibt
es konkret bei diesem Papier schließe
ich nicht aus es ist hier nicht um
zusätzliche Informationen geht und
einfach umverteilungskämpfe in der
russischen Elite das russische
Wirtschaftsministerium hat ja das
bereits kommentiert und sie haben gesagt
es ist so ein Schreckenszenario dass wir
jetzt einsetzen um zu zeigen was gemacht
werden muss aber ich glaube man muss da
wirklich zwischen zwei verschiedenen
Fragen unterscheiden die eine sind
wirtschaftliche und die andere sind
politische Wirkung in der Sanktion das
russische Wirtschaft durch Sanktionen
geschwächt wird ist unumstritten da
brauchen wir das gar nicht zu
diskutieren was interessant ist weniger
als viele gedacht haben weil russische
Wirtschaft im Kern eine Marktwirtschaft
ist ein Marktwirtschaft und passen sich
an aber und es auch eigentlich für
sanktionsforschung nichts Neues
Sanktionen führen zu extrem geringem
politischen Schaden für Putins Regime im
Gegenteil gerade westliche Sanktionen
sind einer der zentralen Gründe warum
Putin jetzt schafft die Russen in Russen
hinter sich zu bringen sie haben ja
Visum Sanktionen indirekt erwähnt es ist
ein wunderbares Beispiel ich habe nach
dem Anfang der europäischen Diskussion
von zwei extrem Putin kritischen
Personen in Russland mal gehört ja er
hat eigentlich recht die sind
tatsächlich gegen uns also mit
Sanktionen habe eine rativ aufgebaut das
Putin wunderbar ausnutzen kann und wir
haben Russinnen und Russen viel
abhängiger von Putin gemacht
wirtschaftlich als sie vor dem Krieg war
es gibt ja eine große Angst Professor
Neitzel vor Energieknappheit und
Rezession im Winter mit auch
gravierenden Folgen bei uns also wenn
wir dann auch davon betroffen von
Sanktionen oder von dem der
Gegenmaßnahme nämlich gasknappheit jetzt
gibt es ja
Überlegungen wenn schon Nord Stream 1
nicht mehr liefert weil es angeblich da
repariert werden muss obwohl Siemens
sagt die Leitung oder die die Pipeline
die funktioniert wunderbar dann lass uns
doch Nord Street 2 aufmachen
diese Vorschläge gibt es ja tatsächlich
zumindest in der Öffentlichkeit was
würde das bedeuten wir sollten uns nicht
am Nasenring von Putin durch die magnese
ziehen lassen also es gibt genug
Leitungen es gibt genug Röhren über die
Erdgas geliefert werden kann und dass
wir nun genau sagen der falsche weg und
ich würde immer sagen also auch diese
Idee
die Russen die müssen wir gewinnen die
sollen nicht gegen Putin sein das ist
mir alles echt sympathisch aber wir sind
letztlich im Krieg mit Russland auch
wenn wir nicht Kriegspartei sind aber
wir sind parteiisch und
also wenn man das würde ja letztlich
diese Argumentation mit den Sanktionen
darauf hinauslaufen dass man sagt und
wir liefern zwar Waffen da Ukraine
machen aber keine Sanktionen weil dann
merken die Russen wir sind nett und die
können reisen die können KDW einkaufen
und siemens liefert weiter Bauteile für
russische Marschflugkörper und wir sehen
dann genau
die wirken das sind genau die Sanktionen
die wirken und das soll man nicht
durcheinander werfen denn die russischen
Bürger die vielleicht im KaDeWe
einkaufen wenn die ein bisschen Deutsch
können oder wenn sie da jemanden
begegnen der Russisch kann dann stellen
die eben fest dass die Deutschen keine
Feinde sind dass die putinische
Propaganda eben falsch aber überhaupt
nichts an der Situation einander das
Problem diesen Krieg führt glaube ich
also die Hoffnung es gibt ja keine
Revolutionen aber es wird für die
Zukunft etwas austragen dann wenn der
Krieg vorbei ist meine Großmutter hatte
eine französische Freundin das hat zwei
Weltkriege überstanden und meine Mutter
war dann mit deren Tochter bis an ihr
Lebensende befreundet und diese
persönlichen Beziehungen haben auch dazu
geführt dass es jetzt überhaupt keine
Angst mehr gibt dass Deutschland und
Frankreich jemals wieder militärisch
gegeneinander sind sind wichtig auch bei
den auch bei den Sanktionen ich bin
Mitglied der deutsch-russischen
bürgerkommission und natürlich haben wir
die Arbeit auf Eis gelegt denn es ist
einfach Teil der russischen Propaganda
diese ganze Sache es gibt ein
deutsch-russisches Geschichte in
Geschichte Schulbuch das ist ein
Russland gar nicht erschienen da hat man
zwar zig Sitzungen und sich Geld
reingebuttert das ist ganz eine reine
Propaganda das kriegen deutsche
Diplomaten geschenkt als als also dass
man in diesem Rahmen nicht mehr
weiterarbeitet klar das wäre trotzdem
Freunde haben was wir trotzdem ist
druckerkollegen haben dass wir denen
auch helfen wollen und dass man dann
nicht dahinreisen kann und so das ist
dann natürlich auch ein Schwan ganz kurz
noch wir sind gleich am Ende der Sendung
hält die Solidarität der deutschen mit
der Ukraine auch jetzt wenn im Winter
viele Anfechtungen kommen
ich hoffe schon aber das wird bestimmt
von allen unseren Diskussionen auch
abhängig und auch davon wie die deutsche
Regierung die Ziele kommuniziert ich
glaube das wurde auch nicht definiert
und heute mit Blick darauf dass wir in
der Zeit der Desinformation Leben ist
unglaublich wichtig klar und deutlich zu
kommunizieren was machen was man macht
und warum man das macht und das wünsche
ich mir auch von der deutschen Regierung
und ich hoffe sehr dass wir ja dass wir
Diskussionen weiter fortsetzen würden
ich Kaffeesatz lesen aber trotzdem
Waffenstillstand das wäre ja das erste
Ziel gibt es da für sie eine Idee weil
wir soweit sein könnten die Leute fragen
ja auch immer danach Krieg ist ja immer
wenn Krieg geführt wird ist immer die
Frage wann ist er endlich zu Ende für
die Ukraine ist Waffenstillstand keine
Option der Sieg der Ukraine dass es das
was die Ukraine macht und daran arbeitet
die Ukraine und ich hoffe sehr dass wir
nicht über den Waffenstillstand sprechen
werden das werden wir aber was sinnvoll
oder was weniger sinnvoll ist noch sehr
oft in der Phoenix zu tun darüber
sprechen ich bedanke mich bei meld dich
bei Ute Fink Krämer bei Professor
Alexander Liebmann und bei Professor
Sönke Neitzel die nächste Phönix
geschwächse und Liebe ZuschauerInnen
liebe Zuschauer ist am Sonntag um 11 Uhr
Phönix persönlich so dass bei Inga Köhn
ist Ricardo lange der zu einer gewissen
Berühmtheit gebracht hat als
intensivkrankenpfleger während der
corona-pandemie und auf die Missstände
in seinem Berufsumfeld hingewiesen hat
auf dem Höhepunkt den bisherigen
Höhepunkt der corona-pandemie
weiteres und aktuelle sind Phoenix der
Tag mit Thomas Bade dazu die neuesten
Meldungen und natürlich in einem
besonderen Schwerpunkt zum Tod von Queen
Elizabeth und es geht auch noch um den
zinsschnitt bzw Zinsschritt
Entschuldigung der Europäischen
Zentralbank der heute stattgefunden hat
bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]